yes help you I used to live here
won't you come in it's the least I can
do is it like you remember cleaner well
you feel free to look around while I get
the water boiling
your hair is
[Music]
[Music]
there you go
awesome music I do apologize
it gets so very hot here this time of
year it's fine what do you feel like you
could just about die but you know what
they say about dairy hmm no one who dies
here ever really dies
but tell me how is it being back in
Derry it's got a strange strange oh my I
had some cookies in the oven before you
came Steve right there I shouldn't
impose I'm gonna no I insist
we photos are lovely miss Kirsch are
these your family my father came to this
country with $14 in his pocket what did
he do mrs. Kirsch my father joined the
circus
I was always daddy's little girl what
about you are you still his little girl
Beverly are you
[Music]
smear the losers club is officially
begun
[Music]
I'm doing this but you have to stick
together
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]